[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 en
los primeros cinco meses de 2021 se
registraron 423 de feminicidios en
méxico un alza del 7,1 por ciento en
comparación con el año anterior en lo
que va del año 100.000 ya fueron
atendidas en 55 centros de justicia para
las mujeres el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador os dijo que el gobierno se
está ocupando del tema pese al
desacuerdo de movimientos activistas y
al temor que expresan las ciudadanas de
a pie veamos
asesinadas por ser mujeres 423
ciudadanas americanas que pierden la
vida en los primeros cinco meses de
gando el 21 víctimas de feminicidio los
crímenes están marcados por una alta
impunidad para los agresores en un
sistema de justicia que no se pone del
lado de las mujeres dígame usted si la
autoridad los sueltan
dónde voy a ir yo a protegerme un crimen
que aumentó más del 7 por ciento en el
país según cifras oficiales pero la
estadística sería mucho mayor
cientos no denuncian por miedo que nos
enfrentamos a un sistema en cune que en
lugar de procurar la justicia procura la
impunidad porque desde el primer momento
que nosotros nos acercamos a ellos se
duda de nuestra palabra se duda de las
marcas en nuestros cuerpos el gobierno
dice estar atendiendo el problema tras
años y años dando la espalda que durante
décadas la cifra oficial
minimizó el feminicidio lo borro
disfrazo y negó lamentablemente este
flagelo ha existido y hay referencias
conceptuales desde 1976 pero el primer
caso reconocido en mexico se registró en
2010 para el cierre de junio la
secretaria de seguridad y protección
ciudadana rosa icela rodríguez presentó
un informe sobre las acciones de las
autoridades
que incluyen 100 integrantes de la
guardia nacional listas para apoyar a
las fiscalías un gabinete de género y un
protocolo de atención a mujeres desde la
policía sólo hasta 2019 se logró que
todos los estados mexicanos tipificar en
en sus códigos penales el feminicidio y
la actual administración trabaja para
que en todos los estados quede
consignado como un delito federal y se
castiguen a los culpables
por qué es tan peligroso ser mujer en
méxico vamos al análisis del trabajo que
se hace por proteger a las mujeres con
una representante oficial y con una
activista nos acompañan desde ciudad de
méxico- fabiola alanís titular de la
comisión nacional para prevenir y
erradicar la violencia contra las
mujeres conavim y también ana elena
contreras activista y fundadora de las
del aquelarre feminista bienvenidas
ambas a ellas hoy y vamos a comenzar a
conversando muy rápidamente ana elena
pese a los esfuerzos contra el
feminicidio hay un sistema estructural
que discrimina desde la justicia desde
las autoridades incluso desde los
hogares de las mujeres el problema
empieza con una cultura abiertamente
machista
es correcto además de que en méxico por
ejemplo tenemos un sistema muy bueno
tenemos muchos protocolos tenemos la
alerta de violencia de género que
pareciera que tendría que apoyar a
apoyar a las mujeres a obtener justicia
a sus familiares y demás el principal
problema con el que nos encontramos es
el machismo que se encuentra instalado
en servidores y servidoras públicos
cuando empiezan a querer acceder a ver
los peritajes ahí es el primer tropiezo
que se tiene con peritajes que están mal
elaborados o que están en desajustados a
la realidad que se quiere
e impactar
con esta necesidad de culpabilizar a las
mujeres por lo que nos pasa no de
hacernos responsables por nuestra
seguridad sin dar el mensaje de que los
violentadores son quienes tendrían que
estar respondiendo por esta violencia y
no nosotras no y es que en estas
declaraciones e incluso en la rueda de
prensa del palacio nacional en la que se
habló del tema el 28 de junio pasado
jamás se habló de los agresores es se
habla mucho es de las mujeres se perece
otro lado también lo necesitamos fabiola
un reto que tienen desde conavim es
lidiar con la llamada lista negra la
cifra de las mujeres desaparecidas el
gobierno registra un aumento de los
feminicidios y dice que está
comprometido con mostrar las cifras
reales sin embargo se quedan por fuera
todas las que no pueden o no quieren
denunciar además del problema de la
tipificación
y el principal reto en materia de acceso
a la justicia para las mujeres es
precisamente combatir la impunidad
porque la mayoría de los delitos que
ocurren en contra de las mujeres no
tienen una sentencia que es con lo que
batallamos todos los días con las áreas
responsables de esta tarea y
efectivamente hay todo digamos cada día
hemos logrado un mayor número de mujeres
se atrevan a denunciar porque en falda
es complicado creer en la justicia
cuando se re victimiza cuando las
mujeres acuden a ministerios públicos y
se les cuestiona se duda de su palabra
se le repetí misa entonces ese digamos
es nuestra tarea de todos los días
decirle a las mujeres pues que se
atrevan y que acudan con nosotras
porque queremos prevenir queremos evitar
que ocurran estos delitos estos 10
feminicidios que desafortunada y
tristemente ocurren en nuestro país
todos los días y que además méxico no es
y también hay que decirlo la excepción
desafortunadamente en el mundo y en
nuestra región latinoamericana brasil
honduras el salvador ocupan los primeros
lugares pero bueno eso es un fenómeno
que tiene que ver efectivamente con una
cultura patriarcal una cultura machista
con la cultura que subordina a las
mujeres a un papel oa una idea de objeto
sexual que es el es digamos que se les
da ese ese trato se cosifica la figura
de las mujeres la mujer que se puede
desechar la mujer que se puede maltratar
la mujer que se puede asesinar contra
eso hay que batallar por los días
tenemos que batallar todos los días y
además fabiola se están haciendo
esfuerzos desde la capacitación a la
fuerza pública pero esto lamentablemente
no va
a solucionar el problema de fondo si el
grueso de la población sigue tratando a
las mujeres como usted nos dice como
ciudadanas de segunda clase o como
propiedad de sus compañeros hombres
entonces quisiera preguntarle hacia esa
dirección que están haciendo cuáles son
los esfuerzos para implementar educación
en la prevención mucho trabajo con los
hombres mucho trabajo con los hombres
porque es cierto
y te lo digo porque hemos atendido en
este en este año no queda el año a 305
casos de mujeres 57 de los cuales han
sido feminicidios cuáles es nuestro
papel y nuestro papel es vincular con
las autoridades atender a las víctimas
indirectas ver que se utilicen los
protocolos pedirle a las fiscalías que
está la muerte violenta de mujeres sea
iniciada como feminicidio esa es nuestra
labor del día a día y que hemos
observado cuando vemos el perfil y el
tipo de delitos
el tipo digamos de violencias que
ocurren en contra las mujeres y las
niñas y estamos observando que en estos
305 casos absolutamente todos tuvieron
que ver con una relación de parentesco
con el entorno más cercano de las
mujeres
por ejemplo tuvimos un monstruoso
feminicidios de una niña de un año nueve
meses quien se atrevió a atentar contra
esta niña a violarla de tal manera que
le ocasionó un desgarre y el y la muerte
casi automáticamente que era el ni más
ni menos que el tío de la menor que se
había quedado a cargo de ella que la
mamá le había confiado la mamá todo te
sale a trabajar le confió a la niña y
ocurrió eso por qué y por qué este
hombre se atrevió a hacer eso por qué
por qué por qué está enraizado en la
cultura que las mujeres somos
podemos ser usadas desechadas
maltratadas violentadas contra eso es
contra lo que estamos batallando y la
instrucción del presidente ha sido
ningún delito debe quedar en la
impunidad y no vamos a estar primar
recursos y esfuerzos para que las
mujeres sean atendidas entonces el
entorno más cercano a las mujeres el más
preocupante y por eso yo insisto tanto
en el tema de la educación y no tengo
palabras para para responder la
situación que nos cuenta ana elena de
ella para ir cerrando qué acciones
reclaman ustedes para que las mujeres y
las niñas sean realmente protegidas para
que no tengan miedo de acercarse a la
justicia el empobrecimiento y la
discriminación y la vulnerabilidad son
además transversales a las agresiones ni
siquiera hemos empezado a hablar de las
mujeres indígenas de las mujeres rurales
de las mujeres afroamericanas que son
las que están además en peligro y con
menos acceso a la justicia
claro pues lo primero que se tendría que
tomar en cuenta es que los hombres
siguen pensando que las mujeres y las
niñas somos desechables que nuestras
vidas y nuestros cuerpos y la dignidad
de nuestros cuerpos no importan por el
grado de impunidad por cada feminicida y
por cada violador que sale libre sí y
que amenaza a las familias de estas
víctimas es que se sigue dando esta
mensaje institucional porque eso no lo
podemos sacar de la ecuación no el
mensaje institucional que se continúa
dando ante la impunidad en los casos de
violencia contra mujeres y niñas es que
nuestras vidas no importan y que los
violentadores pueden seguir haciendo lo
que están haciendo con nosotras no en
las campañas al menos en ciudad de
méxico por parte de la secretaría de las
mujeres empiezan un poco a cambiar
de enfoque pero necesitamos que en todo
el país
el enfoque siga siendo el mismo que los
mensajes sigan siendo para los ojos
violentadores y eso es lo que lo que
necesitamos que se hagan y que se hagan
o la educación que sí tiene que empezar
en la familia no pero ante algunas
características especiales como la
pobreza extrema la necesidad de que
salgan los familiares a trabajar no papá
o mamá que se tengan que encargar a los
menores a otras personas
hay una serie de cuestiones que impactan
en este sentido no y que tiene que ver
con una precarización laboral económica
más allá de la educación entonces
necesitamos que institucionalmente se
deje descargando el mensaje de que la
vida y la dignidad de las mujeres y de
nuestros cuerpos no importa no importa
cuándo empieza a haber justicia estemos
acceder a la cosa
este mensaje va a cambiar muchas gracias
a las dos por estar en ellas hoy con
esta conversación más que importante y
el mensaje que seguiremos repitiendo
hasta el cansancio la mujer no se toca
no se viola no se mata sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]